Recall that our original purpose was the
find a transformation of the formula,
such that a truth assignment
satisfied the original, if and
only if it could be extended
to the transformed formula.
And we've seen how to do this
transformation for a single clause.
But actually, this is enough.
We can just transform
each clause individually.
Introducing a new set of variables for
each.
All the same arguments
about extending or
restricting the truth
assignment will hold.
Let's illustrate what a transformation
of a multi clause formula
looks like with an example.
Consider this formula here,
where I've indexed the literal
Z with two indices now.
The first,
referring to the clause it's in,
and the second being it's
enumeration within the clause.
The first clause only has two literals.
So we transform it into these
two clauses with three literals
by introducing a new variable, y11.
It gets the first one because it
was generated by the first clause.
We transform the second clause with
five literals into these three clauses,
introducing two new variables y21,
and y22.
Note that these are different from the
variables used in the clauses generated
by the first original clause.
Since all these sets of
variables are disjoint,
we can assign them
independently of each other and
apply all the same arguments as
we did to individual clauses.
That's how CNF can be reduced to 3-CNF.
And of course, this transformation
runs in polynomial time,
making the reduction polynomial.
We just reduced the problem of
finding a satisfying assignment to
a general CNF formula,
to the problem of finding a satisfying
assignment to a 3-CNF formula.
At this point, it's natural to ask,
can we go any further?
Can we reduce this problem to a 2-CNF?
Well, no, not unless p is equal to np.
There is a polynomial time algorithm for
finding a satisfying
assignment to a 2-CNF formula,
based of finding strongly
connected components in a graph.
Therefore, if we could reduce 3-CNF to
2-CNF, then p would be equal to np.
So, 3-CNF is as simple as
the satisfiability question gets.
And it admits some very clean and
easy to visualize reductions
that allow us to show that
other problems are np complete.
We'll go over two of these.
First, the reduction to independent set,
or clique, and then to subset sum.